[Applause]
[Music]
give me one minute and i will show you
how persistent disks are a great block
storage option for your virtual machines
persistent disk is high performance
solid state and hard disk drive block
storage that can be attached to
instances
running in compute engine or google
kubernetes engine
standard persistent disk or hdd is low
cost and best suited for large data
processing workloads that primarily use
sequential ios
ssds are better for high performance
apps and databases that require
lower latency and more iops you can
create persistent disk through the
console by selecting the disk type
and where you want it then attach it to
the virtual machine
you can also use the gcloud command line
interface to create and attach the disk
persistent disks are located
independently from vm instances
meaning you can detach or move disks to
keep your data even after you delete
your instances
sharing content is also a snap since
many virtual machines can read data from
a single disk
and you don't have to worry about
downtime because you can resize the
storage on demand without having to
restart the vm
or reattach the volumes for high
availability
create regional storage replicating and
automated geo-replicated snapshots
on the security front persistent disks
are automatically encrypted to protect
your data
so next time you're looking to add
reliable and affordable storage to your
vm
take a minute and look at persistent
disk to learn more check out
cloud.google.com
persistentdisk
you